and we continue to take steps to do so
I'm sure you all saw during the Super
Bowl to during the Super Bowl yesterday
to donate to earthquake relief efforts
and I want to point out some resources
just for that there's a page on USA AIDS
has a list where they have a list of
vetted organization responding to this
crisis should individuals want to
contribute you can find that at
cidi.org in Turkey our Urban search and
rescue teams continue their efforts
assisting in live rescues over the
weekend we also continue to support the
Turkish teams on the ground U.S military
helicopters are providing critical lift
for U.S and international responders our
teams also continue to conduct
structural damage assessments of
buildings with the hope of being able to
clear as many as possible today they
have assessed more than 5 500 buildings
allowing thousands of people who are
currently displaced to be able to return
home in Syria cross-border age shipments
have increased yesterday a fourth U.N
Convoy of 10 trucks from a U.S supported
humanitarian partner successfully
crossed into Syria from turkey that
brings the total to 52 U.N trucks but
more needs to be done it's critical for
the security Council to authorize two
additional Crossings to help deliver
life-saving assistance we cannot delay
any longer again I want to emphasize
that any U.S or International sanctions
include exemptions for humanitarian
medical food and other Aid and one last
thing before I turn it over to the
Admiral I just wanted to make sure we
addressed this from the White House I
know there have been questions and and
concerns about this but there is no
again no indication of aliens or
extraterrestrial activity with these
recent takedowns again there is no
indication of aliens or terrestrial
activity with these recent takedowns
wanted to make sure that the American
people knew that all of you knew that
and it was important for us to say that
from here because we've been hearing a
lot about it
um I I I'm not
jealous I'm just you know I loved E.T
the movie but I'm just gonna leave it
there
um
with that with all seriousness I know
there's a lot of questions about the
flying objects Admiral John Kirby is
here with us today and he's going to
have a Topper a couple things to say at
the top about it and then take your
questions okay
thanks for clearing that up
makes my job easy
I I do have uh quite a few comments here
at the top so I do I hope that you'll
just uh bear with me and then be happy
to take whatever questions you uh you
might have
so uh I'd like to begin today by
updating you on our efforts to recover
the debris of several objects that the
United States Air Force shot down over
the last few days as well as that of the
Spy balloon belonging to the People's
Republic of China
and I'd like to put into some context
for you how we have worked and are still
working to better understand the issue
of high altitude low speed craft
now let me start with a Chinese program
when President Biden came into office he
directed the U.S intelligence Community
to do a broad assessment of Chinese
intelligence capabilities and to assure
and to ensure that we were working to
detect and to protect against them
I think for reasons that you will all
understand we cannot publicly go into
many details about how we discover and
counteract foreign intelligence
collection efforts because much of what
we have done and are doing is of course
sensitive
but we were able to determine that China
has a high altitude balloon program for
intelligence collection that's connected
to the people's Liberation Army
it was operating during the previous
administration but they did not detect
it we detected it we tracked it
and we have been carefully studying it
to learn as much as we can
we know that these PRC surveillance
balloons have crossed over dozens of
countries on multiple continents around
the world
including some of our closest allies and
partners
we assessed that at this time these
balloons have provided limited additive
capabilities to the prc's other
intelligence platforms
used over the United States
but in the future if the PRC continues
to advance this technology it certainly
could become more valuable to them
the President also instructed the
intelligence Community to take a broad
look at the phenomenon of unidentified
aerial objects
indeed President Biden conducted the
first ever daily intelligence briefing
session devoted to this phenomenon back
in June of 2021. he was briefed that
this is not just an issue for the United
States but one for the rest of the world
and as I said our friends and our
partners are dealing with this as well
we worked on a bipartisan basis to stand
up an office at the Pentagon to study
this
in partnership with the intelligence
Community academic institutions and the
private sector
these unidentified aerial phenomena have
been reported for many years without
explanation or deep examination by the
government
President Biden has changed all that we
are finally trying to understand them
better
now in light of the Chinese balloon
program and this recent incursion into
our airspace
the United States and Canada through
NORAD have been more closely
scrutinizing that airspace including
enhancing our radar capabilities which
as the commander of North Common NORAD
General van hurk said just last night
May at least partially explain the
increase in the objects that have been
detected
slow moving objects at high altitude
with a small radar cross section are
difficult to detect on radar even
objects the size of a the Chinese Bible
which had a payload the size of roughly
three school buses were not picked up by
previous administrations or other
countries
we also know that a range of entities
including countries companies research
and academic organizations operate
objects at these altitudes for purposes
that are not nefarious at all including
scientific research
that said because we have not yet been
able to Def definitively assess what
these most recent objects are
we acted out of an abundance of caution
to protect the security our security our
interest and flight safety
in Saturday's case
we acted in consultation with the
Canadian government the president
speaking personally with the with prime
minister Trudeau
the Spy balloon was of course different
because we knew precisely where that was
as we have said
we do not assess that these most recent
objects posed any direct threat to
people on the ground and we are laser
focused on confirming their nature and
purpose including through intensive
efforts to collect debris in the remote
locations where they have fallen
in each instance we have followed the
same basic course
we assessed whether they posed any
kinetic threat to people on the ground
they did not
we assessed whether they were sending
any communication signals
and detected none
we looked to see whether they were
maneuvering or had any propulsion
capabilities
we saw no signs of that
and we made sure to determine whether or
not they were manned
they were not
we did however assess that their
altitudes were considerably lower than
the Chinese high altitude balloon and
did pose a threat to civilian commercial
air traffic
and while we have no specific reason to
suspect that they were conducting
surveillance of any kind we couldn't
rule that out
that is why the president at the
recommendation the secret of the
Secretary of Defense the chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff and the north
North com NORAD Commander gave the order
to shoot them down
these missions were completed
successfully and safely efforts are
actively underway right now at all sites
to find what is left of those objects so
that we can better understand and
communicate with the American people
what they are
I think it's important to remind the
objects in Alaska and Canada are in
pre-remote Terrain
ice and Wilderness all of that making it
difficult to find them in winter weather
the object over Lake Huron
Now lies in what is probably very deep
water
so outside of recovery operations what
are we doing
well first
We are continuing to monitor
there are no active tracks today
but the professionals at NORAD will
continue to do their important work
secondly we are Consulting with allies
and partners on the challenge of
identified aerial phenomenon
and how we can all work together
to deal with that challenge
the president has directed the secretary
of state Secretary of Defense
and the Director of National
Intelligence to engage with their
relevant counterparts to share
information and to try to gain their
perspectives as well again this is an
issue that affects everybody around the
world
third we will continue to brief members
of Congress and relevant State
leadership on what we are doing and what
we learn president has made this a very
top priority
we have over the course of just the last
few days and certainly over the course
of last week reached out to inform and
brief members of Congress and relevant
State governors of the operations that
we were conducting and other recovery
operations that are underway we've also
kept Congress briefed generally on this
issue of Chinese surveillance balloons
including classified briefings last
August
and last week Administration officials
provided classified briefings for all
senators and all members of the House of
Representatives on the PRC surveillance
balloon we fully expect and anticipate
and support
the ability to continue these briefings
in the days ahead
and fourth
the president through his National
Security adviser has today directed an
interagency team to study the broader
policy implications for detection
analysis and disposition of unidentified
aerial objects that pose either safety
or security risks every element of the
government will redouble their efforts
to understand and mitigate these events
and I'm happy to take some questions
um John if the objects don't pose a
military threat and they don't pose a
threat to anybody on the ground why
shoot them down particularly because the
military has uh is routinely monitoring
radar you know radar blips I kind of
covered that in the opening statement
um two real reasons here
first there was a very real potential
risk to civilian air traffic
the ones shut down on Saturday I'm sorry
yesterday was about 20 000 feet and the
two shot down Friday and Saturday were
at about 40 000 feet and as you know
transcontinental air traffic is roughly
around thirty thousand feet it depends
of course on on weather and so because
we assessed that they weren't manned and
weren't being controlled
therefore left to atmospheric conditions
um the the real risk to safety of flight
was was a problem the second purpose and
I talked about this earlier too was even
though we had no indications
that any of these three objects were
surveilling we couldn't rule that out
and so there you know you want to err on
the side of safety here in terms of
protecting our national security
interests and the fact that these
objects uh could have and uh and likely
did at some point in their path uh
Transit over you know potential military
sites of ours or sensitive sites so
again out of an abundance of caution for
those two reasons the president with the
recommendation of his military leaders
directed them to be taken down because
it's so unprecedented did
um should the public be hearing from the
president directly on this
we have been
I think as transparent as we can be I
won't speak for the president's uh
personal uh speaking schedule but I mean
he has been deeply engaged in uh every
one of these decisions he's been kept
informed including as of this morning on
what's going on with recovery efforts
um and uh and he's very much staying on
top of the issue and uh and directing
his team
to make sure we are properly Consulting
and briefing not just members of
Congress but State leaders as well and
of course you know we're also doing what
we can in the in the public sphere
thank you John what is the president's
standard going to be going forward about
when he orders an unidentified object
shot down
it's it comes down to
one simple formulation and that's if at
the recommendation of his military
leaders he believes that the Safety and
Security of the United States the Safety
and Security of the American people is
prime responsibility warrant that kind
of a decision so it's possible we could
see these shoot Downs on a regular basis
like we saw over the weekend I don't
think it's useful for me to get ahead of
where we are right now the president
will always side on preserving and
protecting the Safety and Security of
the American people
you said flying any surveillance
balloons over China are we flying any
other kind of surveillance craft
routinely over China you're not flying
surveillance balloons over China I'm not
aware of any other craft that we're
flying over into Chinese airspace and
then finally can you tell us anything
more about this octagonal object how big
was it we're still trying to assess uh
what what that was I'm not gonna get
into a description I've seen the Press
reports about what what it looked like
um I I think we all need to be humble
here in in terms of what our ability is
to positively identify stuff from
fighter aircrafts that are going several
hundred miles an hour past essentially
in terms of relative motion a stationary
object
um that was not very big
um so we don't know what this exactly
looked like and again we're still not
sure exactly what what it what the
purpose of it was or who owned it but we
we hope to be able to find out more once
we can recover the debris from that one
and from the other two as well
um just a few minutes ago prime minister
Trudeau said that there's some sort of
pattern to the objects over the last few
days is that something you could
elaborate on what sort of pattern the
White House has seen I'm not familiar
with the prime minister's comments so I
I don't know if I uh if I should take a
swing at that I would just tell you that
going back to what I said before uh
these objects were not being maneuvered
they did not appear to have any
self-propulsion
so the likely hypothesis is that they
were being moved by the prevailing winds
and maybe perhaps that's what the prime
minister is talking about I don't want
to speak for him but certainly as the
prevailing winds particularly at that
altitude go west to east across the
North American
airspace I mean there was a general
common movement in in that regard and
you spoke at the top about kind of
reassessing radar given what happened
with with the initial balloon can you
give us a sense can we expect uh should
we assume that this is the the regular
number of these objects over the United
States that they've always been there
and they just haven't been um looked at
the same way or is there any reason to
expect that this is this is more than
usual that are flying so two thoughts
there I mean I I think
um
I think we can all
get our heads around the fact that that
there are sometimes uh things floating
at high altitudes for various purposes
as I said scientific research weather
weather balloons uh all manner of uh of
uh of innocuous craft uh can can be
Aloft at high altitudes I don't think
that that's necessarily unusual here
it's difficult for for me to say exactly
what you can expect going forward
one of the reasons that we think we're
seeing more is because we're looking for
more as you heard General van hurt
mentioned last night they have
they have modified the filters and the
gains as we call it of the of the the
radar capabilities to look more
discreetly at high altitude small radar
cross section and low speed objects and
so if you do that and anybody that's
operated a radar will know you can set
you can set the parameters and if you
set the parameters in such a way that to
look for a certain something it's more
likely that you're going to find a
certain something
given all you've discussed during the
action of the administration of taking
and what people have learned Chinese spy
balloon this year in previous years
these unidentified objects that we shoot
down they might have a question when it
comes to these higher altitudes our
America's borders secure
president takes as I said earlier he
takes our national security uh extremely
seriously he has no higher
responsibility than the Safety and
Security of the American people and I
don't think you need to look any further
quite frankly than the decisions he's
made in just the last week to 10 days to
evidence that but it feels like he's
plugging holes like these are
vulnerabilities that we are discovering
in real time you're making an assumption
there that I don't know that the I don't
know that the analysis will actually
Bear out
thank you very much
um the president gave the order to shoot
down the island over Lake Huron
yesterday where was he what kind of
information did he have when he gave
that order what was brief to him and and
how did he anticipate the outcome of
that he was here in the white house he
was kept constantly informed by uh by
his National Security team and certainly
by the military
um uh he made that decision I don't
couldn't give you the exact time on the
clock but it was uh I believe uh mid to
late morning
um and uh and then it was executed in
the in the afternoon
hurt where they're continuing season
place in case there was a reaction from
a foreign government in reaction to
shooting that object down
yesterday the one yesterday yeah well it
was
shot over I mean it was shot over Lake
Huron and landed in what we believe to
be the Canadian side of the lake so we
were obviously in constant communication
and consultation with our Canadian
counterparts and they are rightly
because of where we think it splashed
down I mean there's sort of the in
concert with the U.S Coast Guard but
they are also involved in in trying to
locate the debris right now but there
was good communication with our Canadian
allies signs of a foreign government
taking a special interest in that object
from yesterday reacting in an unusual
way no okay let's be in the back yeah
thanks uh uh John two questions one you
mentioned early on that um
this the the China uh balloon might have
been giving limited additive
capabilities I assume you're
um meaning on to their satellite
surveillance can you specify what I mean
what exactly it's getting from a balloon
that they're not getting from orbiting
satellites that gold verse like dozens
with the caveat that we haven't fully
recovered everything though we have
recovered some things from the bottom of
the uh of the Atlantic and we're
analyzing that but with that caveat that
we don't know exactly uh what this uh
balloon uh was surveilling or what its
capabilities were so just in general and
I that's an important caveat that I'd
like you to remember
um when you are at a lower altitude then
space
you could perhaps get a better Fidelity
of uh of uh of uh of imagery for
instance uh of things on the ground uh
when you are not moving at the speed of
a satellite and therefore you know only
getting seconds over a a site when you
can maneuver
Left Right Slow Down Speed up like this
thing could then you can loiter if you
can loiter you can soak in a little bit
more you can spend more time over a
sensitive site
of some of their satellites are in
geostationary orbit I mean they're just
sitting there Gathering signals
intelligence right so um
what is the benefit I mean is it just to
see what kind of fidelity we're going to
learn more I'd rather not go into any
more detail than that right now we're
going to learn more
um and frankly I think that's a terrific
question you should be asking Beijing
and as well the um you said that uh
before the other object shot down were
not able
to transmit or we're not transmitting
signals that they did not have any
option did the China balloon did that
have any um was it emitting signals back
I'm not going to go into more detail
about the capabilities of that we are
going to be studying it and analyzing it
there is no question in our minds that
that system was designed to surveil that
that was an intelligence asset I'll
leave it there
Outreach from anywhere in the
administration to the kinds of companies
that produce
weather balloons or other
craft that would fit these descriptions
that might be from the commercial or
corporate world to say is this yours or
any kind of Outreach or have you been
hearing from anyone who might say we
have ours they're in this area is any of
that going on now I don't know of any
conversations right now uh Kelly but one
of the reasons why the president
directed Mr Sullivan to put together an
interagency effort is to take a long
look at that and try to learn a little
bit better about who
is up at that altitude doing what uh for
a completely legitimate purposes I think
we we all recognize we need to probably
have a better side picture on that and
that's why the president wants the
center agency effort to take a look
I'm kind of intelligence might be
happening in terms of the diplomacy
that's going on or whatever if these are
state-owned uh
objects I'm not sure I understand what
you mean is there is there a network of
conversations that might be happening
where someone might be able to say based
on this
octagonal description that hey that
sounds like the so-and-so I mean
is there some conversations that are
happening that might be able to give us
some descriptions I mean the short
answer to your question is yes and I
talked about that in my opening
statement the President also directed
secretary blank and secretary Austin uh
director Haynes uh to have these kinds
of conversations with our allies and
partners around the world to share with
them what we're learning but also to see
get that get their perspectives we're
quick to say it's ours but it was for
commercial purposes
yeah again we're going to have those
kinds of conversations with our allies
and partners to see what kind of
experiences that they have had what uh
what we can learn from from them what
perhaps they can learn from us deal with
object or can we call them balloons
still with object
I won't mess that up today on the
corporate angle is there any expectation
that this is going to affect the the
executive order on surveilling the U.S
companies and what they're doing in
China
okay and then um is there and just you
said a moment ago that there's no
knowledge of a U.S balloon or other
craft or Chinese territory just being
cognizant of the fact that China
different definition of what their
territory is than the United States is
there any U.S surveillance aircraft over
Taiwan over the South China Sea that
that would would fit into that there is
no U.S surveillance aircraft over
Chinese in Chinese airspace okay Chinese
claimed Aerospace there's no U.S
surveillance aircraft in Chinese
airspace and then just finally is there
any
um new formal approach that's being
developed as far as how you're going to
deal with these things on a systematic
basis going forward is there well again
again that's what that's exactly what
the the president wants Mr Sullivan to
run as a process an interagency process
to help us as I said in my opening
statement get around the policy
implications here and whether and
whether or not there needs to be any uh
policy changes going forward
um there's no precedent for us Fighters
taking down objects over U.S territories
as far as I'm aware of I guess my
question is
you talked about the The Tweak in the
radar systems yes there's been a tweak
in the threshold for uh the Pentagon uh
presenting to the president president
signing off on military action related
to anything over our airspace I'm not
sure I'm following which I mean the
Chinese is Five Below yeah The Radars
were tweaked which is why you think
you're seeing some of these things right
has the decision about or has a
threshold for the use of Fighters to
take down objects also been tweaked has
it been lowered has it been changed
we've never seen this before all of a
sudden we've seen no actually I'm sorry
I didn't understand it at first no I
mean and you heard General van hurk talk
about this last night and he's using
established protocols
um to engage
Crafton in the air aircraft in the air
that can be legitimately brought down
and as he said last night the best way
to do that certainly in a timely and
efficient effective way was through
fighter aircraft and through the
Sidewinder air-to-air missiles and they
looked at and he talked about this they
looked at other options to try to bring
them down to include gunfire but that
would have presented a greater risk to
the pilots themselves so this was the
safest most effective way to do that now
where we go from here I think we just
don't know right now in terms of whether
there needs to be threshold changes as
you put out
I think it's important to just take a
step back here and and remember what the
president did was ordered these actions
with the Safety and Security of the
American people foremost in his mind
um and there were there were very good
reasons to do it
um the military then once given an order
determines how they're going to execute
that order
and general van hurt decided that the
best way to do this was with Sidewinder
missiles and fighter aircraft point on
it but this isn't reactive to the
Chinese five aluminum in the sense of
there was political pressure and so we
are going to quickly to take down any
objects over our airspace because the
pressure that came from say Republicans
this was this was these were decisions
based uh purely and simply on what was
in the best interest of the American
people
thanks John
um John does the US government have
video or imagery of these latest
intercepts and will you guys be
releasing it you'd have to talk to DOD
about that Jackie I I don't know what
kind of imagery might exist and uh and
they'd be one to talk about whether
they're releasable or not
um obviously
certainly with respect to the Spy
balloon the um we want to make sure that
we are gleaning what we can from this
imagery so that we can answer your
questions better
um and so to what degree there is or
will it will or not be public release I
do want to stress that you know we're
going to want to make sure that we have
had a chance to analyze that imagery uh
for ourselves as much as possible a lot
of fun Phil's question I mean
we're trying to discern as you said
earlier you know we're looking for these
more so we're finding more and I said
that could be one reason why we're
finding one
why are we all
we all said that when the first spy
balloon was crossing over Americans and
Canadian airspace one of the reasons
that he couldn't take action was because
his assessment was that it didn't pose a
military threat or have hostile intent
and so he couldn't take action there it
seems like maybe that protocol has
changed or his his ability to make that
call where there is not an imminent
threat militarily or physically might
have changed so can you explain to us
what change why are we shooting them
down all of a sudden I kind of feel like
I took care of that in my opening
statement but I'm happy to revisit it I
mean really two reasons here
and these are
in certainly in
well in both cases they're different I
think we need to separate the Chinese
Bible and we knew what it was
we knew where it was going
we knew what he was trying to do and by
not taking it down I mean it was also
a huge payload like I said the size of
three school buses so really the option
of shooting that down over land wasn't
the legitimate option because somebody
really could have gotten hurt and we
used the the time available to us
knowing what this thing was all about we
used that time to study it to learn from
it to collect on it
then taking it down at the earliest
opportunity in the water and we have
retrieved some of that debris off the
bottom and we're studying that hang on a
second I'll be right there
um but so let's separate that from these
other three and these other three
what are some of the differences
altitude's a big difference
just let me let me get through this and
then altitude's different
the Chinese spy balloon was at sixty
thousand plus well outside commercial
air traffic concerns
these three
were right on the border of it so there
was a legitimate concern there
Chinese by balloon we knew exactly what
that thing was and we knew what it was
trying to do and we saw it Jackie as it
slowed down sped up maneuvered a little
bit trying to get a look at what we
believe to be sent to the military sites
these other three
they didn't have propulsion they weren't
being maneuvered it was basically
they've been being driven uh by the by
the wind
we don't think we don't we don't know
for sure whether they had a surveillance
aspect to them but we can't rule it out
so there was a little bit there was
enough uncertainty there uh that again
out of an abundance of caution doing The
Prudent thing the president directed
that they get taken down and I I get
where you're going is this the standard
going forward and we're gonna we're
gonna dive into this we're going to
learn from these three events
um we're going to continue to study what
happened we're gonna have an interagency
effort that helps us get around the
policy implications here and we'll see
where this goes but bottom line for
President Biden is you got to do the
right thing for the American people for
our Safety and Security
that no one's claimed these yet as
theirs
uh I I can't say whether that's strange
or not since we're sort of in Uncharted
Territory here no pun intended but we
don't you know we don't we don't know
and I suspect that that
go ahead I'm I'm I'm basically done I'm
basically done
CBS okay um has the payload been
recovered from South Carolina yet
the
called payload that's yeah as I said
some of the debris certainly uh they
were able to take things off the surface
like the next day actually that
afternoon uh some of the balloon uh
fabric
um and in the days since they have been
able to recover some not all uh of the
payload that sank to the bottom of the
Atlantic it's about 45 feet of water
weather conditions are pretty tough off
the coast right now like today for
instance they have not been able to get
into the water and dive on it but over
the course of the weekend they were able
to raise some of the debris including uh
some of the electronics and uh in some
of the structure the expectation of when
all that payload is going to be
collected I don't I wish if I if I could
tell you that I'd be a very wealthy man
I mean it's gonna it could take it could
take a long time uh given uh see the sea
State and weather conditions and the
degree to which we have to protect the
safety of the divers one last question
you said you were unsure of the
surveillance capabilities of these
latest objects
um last week we were told several times
that every precaution was taken to
ensure that the sensitive installations
were covered we don't know exactly what
you all did
but has there been where are you gonna
find out
well it has there been a posture change
Nationwide regarding all of these
sensitive uh sites if you're proactively
if you're
um
let me just put a fork in this if this
if the implication is that you know uh
there's some sort of blanket now
security policy for every base on the
continental United States the answer is
no
we do have protocols particularly when
we we know
um that
um surveillance is going to occur like
in the open Skies tree with Russia for
instance when all that's scheduled and
laid out and when you know that there's
going to be an open Skies flight by uh
by Russia you take the appropriate
actions and that's what we did in the
case of the Chinese by balloon and we'll
always do that I will never talk about
what precautions we're going to make at
any given base at any given time but we
always do what we need to do to protect
our nation's secrets I I won't talk
about it any more than that okay
thank you very much
okay
okay you you started the briefing by
talking about
Baldwin in this the report from uh Odie
and I recently that that goes over this
in that odni report about unidentified
aerial phenomena it says there were 247
unidentified aerial phenomenon reports
since March of 2021. some of which have
quote demonstrated unusual flight
characteristics or performance
capabilities so can you say why the
president
just recently within the last couple
weeks started ordering some of these
objects to be shot down and why there
weren't any orders throughout 2021 or
throughout 2022. it's very it's very
simple
it comes down to what sort of Safety and
Security threats and risk we're talking
about
um and uh uh and also
uh it comes down to a lot to our ability
to attract to track detect and engage
having come from the Pentagon I can tell
you that some of these uaps
while we may not be able to know what
each and every one is doing
some of the big concern there was that
um a lot not many of those reports were
happening around our training ranges
were happening around
air training ranges so combat Pilots
were seeing these things and it was and
there was a potential impact to the
safety of flight of our our Pilots but
you may not have but a fleeting moment
on some of these things to to see it and
so it's different in these cases
um we had time to detect time to analyze
time to engage time to make those kinds
of decisions but it all comes down to
Safety and Security first and foremost
the time though is a matter of
capability you have better capabilities
now than we did we are certainly
improving our capabilities now and and
as I said the president has directed The
National Security team uh to dig into
this deeper from an interagency effort
and to see what uh if other uh
improvements might need to make I mean
look just
just by adapting the way the radar
parameters are set
we have improved our ability to detect
and again I said that could be one
reason why we're seeing more
um so you said that the debris fell on
Frozen Waters or in remote areas and
these are also not huge objects and they
were shot down by Nissan so how
optimistic are you that you will be able
to collect enough debris to really get
an idea of what these objects were
we won't know until we get on site to
see
um you know how much damage was done not
just by uh the missile strike but by the
fall from from a very uh high altitude
and as you said in one case on sea ice
um so we'll just have to see
yeah uh uh thank you John the Secretary
of State Lincoln plan to meet with this
Chinese counterpart this week at the
Munich security conference I'm refer you
to the state department for the
secretary's schedule I I don't have
visibility on that okay and um have you
been able to what have you been able to
learn more uh or not you but the
government since these uh objects were
shot down I mean you you just alluded to
the fact that uh not being able to get
on site yet I mean has there been any
additional information since one was
shot down Friday and then over the
weekend
because these are just happened over the
last few days and we haven't found the
debris
um there's uh there's still a lot more
we expect to be able to learn and I
think once we can get to the debris and
I'm not forecasting how easy that's
going to be they all three have fallen
uh into some pretty remote uh difficult
areas to reach but we're going to do
everything we can to find them and that
will tell us a lot since we have since I
know you didn't ask about this but uh in
the case of the Chinese spy balloon we
have been able to recover some debris
and some of the electronics uh and even
some of the structure from the bottom of
the Atlantic and that will also tell us
a lot and we are uh we're learning from
it right now
everybody
as much debris as you can get from all
the sites I'm sorry when do we think
when do you think you'll be satisfied
that you've gotten as much debris as you
sites I wish I could give you a date
certain on the calendar I can't do that
we're gonna we're we're working to uh
surveil them right now in fact you know
there's a uh an avp3 that's flying over
the site in Alaska the Canadians are in
charge obviously of the one in the Yukon
and now the Coast Guard is in the Lake
Huron working with the uh Canadian Coast
Guard to do the same thing uh there so
we're working this as hard as we can and
we will keep you informed as we learn
more as I'm doing today divers in the
water over the weekend we have recovered
debris off the coast of uh of South
Carolina we'll keep you informed brief
Congress this week there have been
briefings as early as late last week and
we do fully expect that there will be
additional briefings this week perhaps
even perhaps even later today we're
running out of time
they've been very harsh they said the
first balloon was an accident in the
last three objects were not theirs have
you responded that has the White House
had conversations with Beijing about
this and can you share a little bit
about that we know the first one was
Chinese they admitted it they claimed it
was a weather balloon we know it's not
these three we don't have attribution
for right now we don't know we don't
know who owns them so I'm not going to
take anybody's uh word at face value
here until we can get a chance to to
take a look at them are we in touch with
the Chinese
um uh we have we have an embassy in
Beijing we maintain routine diplomatic
conversations and we have had uh in over
that spy balloon incident we did have
private discussions with senior Chinese
leaders okay thanks uh things to enroll
I know you just said that are you in
touch with the Chinese is there any
effort to arrange at all with President
XI I'm not aware of any plans for that
there's a question on Israel does the
president plan to speak with PM
Netanyahu about the moves his government
is making to try to weaken the Israel I
have no calls or conversations to read
out
um uh but we are deeply concerned by
some of the moves here with respect to
settlements
um
just recently has said that there was a
Russian plot to sort of overthrow her
government and break moldova's path to
Europe it was something that President
zielinski himself had also warned about
what is the U.S assessment of this
possible a plot and more broadly what is
the concern about Russia's attempts to
sort of influence these gov these
pro-european governments in the region
even though it's right now focused on
Ukraine about other countries in the
region
so
um
what I'll say about that is uh
deeply concerning reports certainly
not outside the bounds of Russian
behavior and we absolutely stand with
the moldum moldovan government and the
moldovan people we have no no
confirmation from the U.S side of Intel
I know no independent confirmation but
we're certainly not questioning the
capacity the will of the of the Russians
of Mr Putin to try to do that is
perfectly right a page I ran out of his
Playbook
yes I I was going to ask you a question
just one quick question can you
established whether these are lighter
than air or heavier than air we have not
okay but we have to
have already had a question go ahead
um all three shoot Downs in the US
occurred offshore but the one in Canada
occurred over land so is it effective
U.S policy to not shoot down these
objects over land for safety concerns I
wouldn't read it into this some kind of
policy decision we will always in
deciding whether something should be
taken down or not consider the impact on
the ground
when the Chinese uh Pavilion came down
the Chinese foreign Ministry indicated
they would respond in a way that they
were prepared to if it turns out that
the other objects are also Chinese and
origin is the is there a menu of options
prepared to the president for how we
would react terrific hypothetical we're
just not there yet okay yeah so I
realized a relationship issue you have a
the Chinese spy Airship that went
through you've got China buying more oil
from Russia you've got China uh you know
opening up cases in the U.S trying to
steal U.S technology from universities
and the president XI is going to be
meeting with the Iranian president at
what point do you review a big review of
the U.S relationship with China and at
one point does the president ask for a
call from president XI again I don't
have a call to to talk about today let
me just again level said here and I know
I'm uh running close on time but uh
sorry uh but but the president met with
President XI at Bali at the G20 the
whole purpose of that discussion was to
move this relationship forward in a
better way most consequential bilateral
relationship in the world the president
knows that and he wanted to move that
relationship forward uh in a better way
and secretary blinken was dang near
wheels up trying to head to Beijing to
have those kinds of conversations to get
some of these communication vehicles and
venues back on track whether it's
climate change or military to military
we were willing to do that we were
looking forward to doing that
um and then
the Chinese decided to fly a
surveillance balloon over the
continental United States and it
wouldn't be inappropriate to have that
meeting when is when are those
discussions going to get back on the
counter I couldn't tell you uh as you as
secretary blinken has said it'll happen
at the at the appropriate time now is
not that time it doesn't mean and people
shouldn't take away from this that all
communication has been severed between
the United States and China that Beijing
and Washington aren't talking we still
have an embassy there we still have uh
an ability through secretary blanken's
good offices to communicate with senior
uh Chinese leaders unfortunately the
Chinese military is not interested in
talking to secretary uh Secretary of
Defense Austin but but there are still
ways to to communicate and the president
would tell you that now's exactly the
time to at least preserve some of those
lines of communication so that we can
avoid miscalculation how to set back the
relationship
Mr has this all this list of things set
back to relationship it is certainly not
helped us move forward in the way that
we want it to move
no sir
right here James okay me oh thank you
last Friday you answered my question
about President Biden's message during
his trip to Poland but I'm wondering why
he specifically chosen Poland for this
trip since so many countries are helping
Ukraine and he visited Poland 11 months
ago
the president's really looking forward
to this trip
um certainly
not lost I'm sure on any of you that
it's time to round what's sadly is going
to be a year of War Ukraine
Poland has been
a strident Ally a tremendous supporter
of of Ukraine and a generous host not
only to American troops but millions of
Ukrainian refugees who have fled there
in safety the the polls are pardoned
upon but they're punching well above
their weight and and uh and we very much
appreciate all the support president
wants to thank president Duda in person
he wants to thank the Polish people in
person he wants to make broader points
about how it's important for the kind of
courage and unity we're seeing out of
Poland and so many NATO allies continues
sadly into what will now be a second
year of War
thank you
Admiral naturally I have two questions
one on the
um unexplained aerial phenomenal
uh and the second will be on the Russian
Ukraine war
um
my understanding is that uh the top
officials of the Pentagon when asked
explicitly if uh they were ruling out
any kind of extraterrestrial presence
said they weren't ruling anything out
and yet at the beginning of today's
briefing albeit with her usual winning
smile uh Ms Jean-Pierre seemed to rule
out any extraterrestrial activity I
don't think the American people need to
worry about aliens with respect to these
craft period I don't think there's any
more that needs to be said there on the
Russia Ukraine war as we approached the
anniversary
um in the days immediately after the
commencement of the conflict we heard
from senior U.S officials such as the
CIA director in Congressional testimony
that President Putin had been observed
by U.S officials to have constricted his
decision-making Circle during the
pandemic that he was making erratic
decisions and these were seen to have
played out in in what happened on the
battlefield
as we approach this year anniversary
what do we observe about President
Putin's decision making now the caliber
of his decision making and also his grip
on power in his own country has any of
that changed over the course of the year
I can't speak to the way Mr Putin gets
advised and how he
you know who's advising him and what
they're saying I I couldn't begin to get
inside uh Kremlin decision-making
process he's
clearly Mr Putin is not making good
decisions shouldn't have invaded in the
first place this is a country that posed
no threat to anybody let alone Russia
clearly he hasn't made sound decisions
nor has his military with respect to
their performance on the battlefield
they're still suffering some of the same
problems they were a year ago Logistics
sustainment integration of joint fires
uh Manpower Personnel unit cohesion I
could go on and on the Russian military
is still struggling they they have not
surmounted these these problems and it's
borne out by the fact that you know he
continues to change generals the way I
change socks so I mean he's he's still
struggling
yeah guys we have to end the briefing
um I gotta go into the oval but um I
will see you tomorrow and thank you for
the compliment on the smile I appreciate
that but I'll be I'll be back tomorrow
thanks everybody have a great weekend